eminently offline i definitely accepted
you though
okay so now what joined potty
okay that's strange so we have to make a
party
okay how does that work there's
maybe we have to play a game first
before we can party
what play a game before partying
that's absurd that makes no sense did
you finish the tutorial because i still
have eight out of nine
i did finish the tutorial yeah i did i
got to nine out of nine then it said
oh there's hang on hang on hang on yep
okay okay we all got more tutorials to
do lads
i think that's what's happening here
yeah really
well look if i try to go to play i have
to go to the
like okay no no no no no no no no that's
something
squad okay i got it i got it i got it i
got it i clicked i figured it out now
you can join me i think
okay exiting the main menu
[Laughter]
oh no i actually have to finish the
tutorial she said
backfire or i'll send you directly okay
well i can
invite you to do something at the same
time if you click on game mode tutorial
you have to change it from tutorial
correct battle royale
yes i've sent you an invite okay
hello everyone joining me now that i'm
officially live what's up
web uh i'm with uh jacob and uh john and
we're playing a game called spellbreak
and my hair is very wet because i just
finished bleaching it
um i definitely accidentally burnt my
scalp a little bit so that's super fun
but the most important part is that i
feel like it's going to be difficult to
play because there's so much [ __ ]
hair in my eyes because it's wet
it's great if bellatrix lestrange can do
it you can too
thanks man that's the kind of this kind
of confidence that i need to hear i
don't really appreciate she dies though
she gets blown up sick all right i
appreciate it great
um uh there you are there you are
you all [ __ ] ready to do this all
right i'm gonna i'm gonna do yeah
i will allow firewall access yes i have
to do that too
hold on i got to select my class
oh yeah i suppose
i do too yeah i want to be a firebase
coconut
well-balanced area control high flying
well i feel like we should try to
complement each other right i feel like
right now i want to go with the conduit
because i picked a hot boy i'm a
firebender ace what are they called this
game pyromancer
everything changed i'm an airbender okay
great let's do it
we are ready we want to be an airbender
yeah i believe
you could be a fart bender i saw the gas
guy in there too
yeah there is the gas guy by the way
y'all i uh i'm very tired i did a like
seven or eight hour stream yesterday
mm-hmm with like in the physical parts
of it piercing
heat what'd you do i made 30 burritos
well i ended up making 24 burritos
you round up i froze them all i had one
today it was very delicious
why is oh we're waiting on one of you
i've read it i believe
ready okay
tempest confirm great for the record
everyone is watching this is the first
time that every single one of us has
played this game so here we go yeah
it'll go great
yep i don't even know what a keyboard is
every time i played a battle royale the
first time around it's great
oh great my youtube stream is unlisted
let me fix that
i was like why is no one on youtube here
unlisted excellent
going into the tutorial though it was
very very pretty
i mean it could be atrocious to play i
don't know but i guess we'll find out in
approximately five seconds
there we go youtube stream there we go
we got you we got you
okay i did it all right great okay where
are we dropping wizards oh [ __ ]
are we dropping harry uh let
you know what we're gonna be flying in
some like blimp or like an eagle
never mind we're trying to we just
skydive like wizards do
old w to go faster where are we i'm
dropping
right in this i'm dropping on one of the
parapets
oh yeah we got to find our
spells and stuff oh yeah
tornado i mean having this music in a
battle royale is real nice i'm gonna be
honest
i'll go for this one item is already
equipped what is this i will take you
wind gauntlet
ooh what is this i don't think so but i
wanna oh i got a red belt i think it's
only us
at the moment which is uh i don't like
that oh it is a rare toxic gauntlet
though that's pretty sweet
maybe i should grab that okay colin
frost got
it i'll stick with my fart gauntlet cool
stuff a red glove
that's neat yeah so now i have two
i can fart and then blow it in your
direction so again
oh oh what was that did you do that what
is on fire this is me that's i'm just
experimenting don't worry
okay great everyone has that by phase
jacob i understand so
we support you the circle or what is it
called the
the spell sign the ring of the elders
i guess the ring of destiny what was
that oh
that's just me i'm howland is it no
change
i'm exiling them did we are there were
there three of them yeah
just this one one of them and we killed
them they're dead
yeah we could go dash oh my god so many
chests so much stuff
let me read real quick you guys i gotta
read a book okay in my battle right now
where you can
i can use it and detect people actually
i just got rid of it so it's gone now
yeah i like the wolf one a lot well if
you just dropped it can i get it
from wherever it is
down here oh no that's not it it's uh oh
there it is
that we just decimated that dude yeah i
was just looking at chess
he just walked in i think he wasn't even
trying to fight he just walked in
and waved and then we just destroyed him
oh we the batteries
epic teleportation rune okay should we
just keep going like vaguely in this
direction
just keep going i guess so yeah oh we're
about to enter
keep popping that hell to uh see any
enemies
i have teleport there are none there are
no i have a bouncy thing
how many people are in here i have no
idea
does it say somewhere it looks like
there are 26. maybe
26 is what i mean what's that do you
guys see that bowl thing in the distance
what the [ __ ] is that
a bull ball a ball
the ball oh i see it yeah right
he's like a bubble is that the egg of a
hungarian horntail perhaps
oh may happens good so find out what
that is okay cool yeah let's go
investigate
i'm pretty happy with my loadout but i
don't know how important it is
i'm trying to they're items in the way
what's the key
middle mouse i think by default john one
common boots
oh let me just read the scroll real
quick oh they're they're up there
john there where you are you fight some
people
is that what's happening nope you're
aiming this way oh
oh ah i see they are in the ball
i electric stem whoa ah they're almost
dead
they're almost dead there's more than
one good day you son of a [ __ ]
you're right there is more than one oh
he's immune to wind oh he's dead all
right frost
exiled him no no there's one here
there they're dead now okay i think they
both dead
they may be cool
that's neat i like the exile thing
that's pretty sick i got some big boots
uh yes everyone in chat i am i just i
just
dyed my hair so it's currently very wet
and in my face don't worry about it and
do the howl thing
in 20 seconds epic loot will spawn
that'll be alert oh i'm picking
okay uh this is the same room but epic i
will take that
epic
where are they they're right there
they're right there lightning [ __ ]
murder their asses wow we are are we are
we pro gamers
is this our game uh i think everyone
else playing
is uh i still like a legendary gauntlet
from somebody
powerful right now please i don't know
how to paint i don't know how to paint
but right here right here
yep yep yep ignore my thing
no i think that's it i burned his corpse
keep having so we know there's some epic
stuff oop like listen i'm going to want
to win
it i already got cool drops up here
legendary drops take that
we're just howling i'll take a potion
i'll take a potion
i'll take another potion cool
all right feeling good about it there's
some oranges there's an orange fire
glove up here if anyone wants it
is orange like that was my old one yeah
orange is legendary yeah i think i've
got mine already
um okay i'm howling we gotta keep moving
okay don't forget to consume your armor
shards
wait what does that mean i don't know
that i do either okay let's take that
one it
heals your armor okay okay let me take
that
got it that help potion take that belt
armor shower there actually yeah i could
use a lot of armor shots frankly i
we are not looking great on the arma
situation it's probably because john
took them all i don't know what you're
talking about
was this a pain yeah yeah everyone clear
your pinks
oh yeah sorry still not sure how to wear
it
it's metal oh okay i have to look at it
uh well i'm using controller so
you know yeah maybe a controller click
joystick click
a stick click yep correct ignore that
you're right
storm closing in uh we're in the ring
right i feel like
i hear things i'm i'm going to keep
doing the howl so i can see people don't
seem pretty far away i two will continue
to howl
this neat castle i don't have hal i have
spring steps um where if you guys got
your webcams i realized i'm covering
like your
oh yeah mine is uh i have my webcam
doesn't overlap with gameplay i have a
pro set up
i'll fix that we'll fix it okay you'll
fix my oh there's potion shards
there's armor shards up here that's his
dust scroll of the spirit
yeah uh excuse me i have to read give me
a
reading just give me a second to read a
book okay we did it
is that is that our farts or their farts
no i farted
we're just anytime we hear a noise we
just howl the [ __ ] is this getting
scared
i tried to open the chest and i used to
eat i'm glad that
oh you took some ecstasy right now you
popping pills
there are three armor shards up here
baby
i would love that it tells you like hey
you already have a better weapon you
don't need this
yeah it's neat okay okay because i
wouldn't know
otherwise yeah see i'm saying um
i'm upgrading my spirit talent
okay we gotta keep going we need to move
to the circle i could use some more alma
shaw's i only found one
of oh yeah honey but whatever they went
that's suspicious but i thought i had an
epic or a legendary fire glove i have
legendary fart
legendary fought club i'll use my fart
my fire glitter to ignite your fart
glove
oh yeah
okay i keep leveling up and i don't know
what to do with it
i'm like cool but we gotta keep we gotta
just keep out circle's pretty small
let's go to this epic thing
okay or the the spawner thing
oh someone died here yeah for real
yeah that is [ __ ] oh i don't want
anything i see them
okay what do you want to do they're
going to be over there over there shall
we
should we engage or shall we just be
chill what do you what do you want right
there
shall we outgrow let's kill them no
that's [ __ ] good
let's wait for the man of all oh yeah
let's kill them
there's one where'd they go
[ __ ] him up all right are they did we
just do it already
no did they die uh i mean we certainly
killed one of them
keep howling it may have just been one
guy
i think so yeah do we exile them
all right cool happy for us there's the
legendary oh i heard footsteps
want any of this stuff is it mine oh my
hell needs three seconds
no it needs longer uh i don't want any
of this stuff
i like my loadout you know you feel me
all right well the circle's pretty small
this castle is pretty nice here actually
hang on guys just give me a second to
read the scroll you know how it'd be
okay great let's just hole up in this
fortress
i feel like i maxed out on my loots
yeah it happened pretty quick
that's good i feel like when there's too
much
loots it uh kind of takes away
just never really feel confident yeah
um if there's no old floating he's dead
for good
okay i appreciate that chat thank you
it's close
it closed soon uh you guys are having
issues with this program
that means they're gone it's just my air
conditioning you guys i'll turn it off
there you go yeah there you go he's
making plenty of noise
he does that oh yeah yeah i'm i'm
keeping my head on a swivel i'm gonna
keep howling
i hear sounds like magic sounds is that
none of us i too hear the magic sound
over in your direction alana but am i
i'm in agreement
i can't
all right i'm going to regroup with you
guys oh i shoot like a disc i'm going to
hell
howling everything's fine oh god i just
killed him i farted on him
oh yeah okay these are a problem okay
okay
there's one down here there's one down
here literally just walking up then
standing there and
what no that dude's shooting at nothing
i don't think i can aim that far away
i'm skilled and we're overcoming they're
100
bots i don't think that's a ball why is
he running away
good john we're just really good we're
really good at this game
all right stay close stay close
oh alana you're on him yeah
oh i definitely jumped in that
okay okay we're outside the circle we're
outside oh there we are outside the
suburb over there i'm picking
there's only four people left they're
the last ones john are you
i'm
did we wow okay
great fuss game you guys great first
game uh i got three exiles and five
assists good stuff good stuff
what up yup good [ __ ] uh if anyone wants
to play it looks like it's free and
there's
no one else playing so feel free to hop
in no there are loads of people playing
on twitch
um we defeated these wizards in the
whole land
do we hit exit now i guess yeah i
clicked it
good first game you guys ggs all around
gg's all around
good job good first game
[Laughter]
all right they're probably um it's
possible they're populating the first
like our first matches with bots to
teach us but there are definitely a lot
of people playing on twitch so
probably house elves
[Laughter]
all right i'm good
i really like that loadout i don't want
to yeah me too i kind of just want to
like stick with the thing and try
same be good which i understand is
boring but
but i liked it which i guess that's how
i played five hours of overwatch
i only played junkrat so
i mean it's possible it's a mix of both
but again
people definitely be playing the game on
twitch it's a tank this is a bot
so many sounds a lot of sounds happening
yeah
i don't care at all where you want to go
sawtooth mountain literally yeah
i guess that's why we all go there yeah
i didn't even have to click on anything
yeah or we can go to one of those epic
loot spawners
is that a little snowflake well we ran
out of time oh well
all right okay cool well let's drop
can we look around there's like a
redness
in that in that city there is shall we
go to it
let's do it i mean there's a bunch of
white stuff on top of these castles
i want to loot this i don't know i don't
know where you're going now
okay all right somebody dropped me by
that's okay we'll get our stuff first
and obliterate them
uh-huh yeah totally where are they where
are they we're better wizards they
they dropped at the city over so not
directly here basically
just mash f just mash f
[ __ ] yes
get those armor shards i just i just
want my wolf you know
i just want my wolf try that take
potions
armor shards actually it's cool do you
like
because jacob can light it on fire it's
cool that you have like one permanent
gauntlet and then one that you just swap
out yeah yeah i'm down with that
i don't want a stone gold this dude all
right let's go get that nerd
there's an epic fire gauntlet over here
i don't have howling anymore oh i don't
either
and i miss it ping
yeah and
[Music]
alana you know how to ping yet on your
controller yes
cool i'm keeping my eyes peeled
okay oh we should probably head towards
the thing let's go
we're not far from it actually i have
like a red guy john underneath you
todd i have like no armor right now so
there's that i guessed him
oh he's dead exile a [ __ ] jesus exiling
him
okay i don't have howling anymore so we
gotta just actually look for people i
know i feel insecure without howling
it's i really don't enjoy it
i already have that okay okay we need to
wean ourselves
off of it so we can get better at being
aware
that's true oh
[Music]
right that scroll it's fly
he just zoomed up into the air oh yeah
it is that's pretty nice i need armor
shards
oh i have a few but i don't know how i
would give them to you
you know you feel me i don't know if you
can you might just have to i don't have
a belt oh
you have an inventory you can you can
right click to drop there you go
um we don't even have belt yes those
belts yet though jacob and you need a
belt
oh i just got
all right i don't see anyone in red town
that place looks spooky
it does look spooky real spookish
should we head towards the circle oh
we're probably
in 20 seconds okay yeah we're not very
far from it anyways so let's get over
here let's go let's go let's go
uh there might be a slight background
buzz you guys sorry about that also
you guys keep telling me the uh xbox
series x just leaked
i like super duper what like cool i
guess but they're making another
xbox yeah it's like one of the worst
kept secrets
the good thing about magic is somebody
can't snipe you from across the map with
it as far as i know
i'll see about that yeah we'll find out
i don't know if that's true nah that's
true
oh a health potion yeah there's an
earthquake
ocean fire shark hyper class oh [ __ ]
you just have a gun yeah uh finally a
belt
gauntlet that shoots bullets
oh i can upgrade my wind gauntlet cool
is that not the exact same thing
oh i had one i had featherfold and now i
have oh
i don't know if they see us yet well i
shot him so
so probably magic collided in midair
there's
another one in the tower yeah you're
right there's one up there as well
um [ __ ] that's a really good hit he just
got on me get close don't get too close
well i have to i'm reading a scroll
now it's not the time i have to get
close because i am a close combat
uh [ __ ] they're getting me
oh jacob there's three of them consuming
my armor shard
oh they got me i just don't even know
what they are no this is bad i feel like
i should bail
so i
they were disrupting me and i wasn't
sure what it meant jacob
i just got overwhelmed very quickly
there i'm going to be honest that just i
didn't know what was happening
no no all right i like it
yeah they deserve that
and fire is open wind ultimate and fire
is open
says dogor his wizard name
okay cool i'm ready tom
marvol
[Laughter]
thank you for that windows defender i
appreciate that you are defending me
thank you sick
my talents oh i can edit my talents what
balance are passive abilities that grant
you advantages throughout a match you
may selection can reconfigure talents
but here between matches
interesting i can't do anything
um on the bottom right
on your like class selection screen
if i click unready and then ready again
i'm not entirely sure jacob it says
you're still in a match yeah it's a
system
yeah oh
i'm here on the readying unreadying menu
let's do it i'm so ready
i need to get enough wizard coins to buy
a new wizard outfit
hell yeah dude honestly i'm living for
this look at all these things that we
can't take with us
we okay that does that i love you
that does that i need to figure out
where my buttons do
it's a flame wall yeah there's a lot
going on right now
oh it looks like when you don't have a
gauntlet you throw lame little
magic farts at people oh
uh why shall we drop what about
castle block more where's that which one
the bottom
right okay let's go oh yeah all right
let's go to all the coolest sounding
places yeah that's how i decided i just
say it out loud i'm like
castle
looks like there is a big castle
directly beneath us okay let's drop in
the castle
i'm going for a desert world way over
there okay i'm just going straight down
pretty much
uh yeah chad this game is on i believe
every platform
it's also cross-play which rules look at
your cool tricks
you guys like the blue angel um i i'm
not not very
in this game that i feel like such a
calculated launch requires
you know a nice battle apparently there
is a dev in my
twitch chat oh epic chest
oh yeah there's like eight devs in mine
oh that's cool congrats
[Laughter]
i need a belt hang it i mean my wizard
pants are falling down
yeah i could use belt use some boots oh
i got ice glove
ice ice baby freeze your farts
invisibility rune i love that for me
amulet i will take oh are you a belt
dammit
epic feather fall rune what's this dude
up up what what's human what's that
sound
what does it mean
i'm getting attacked as well i'm on my
way i don't have a belt
or cool boots no i don't have anything
useful at all to use in this fight so
that's going to be a bit of a [ __ ] i
see the ones behind you first thing uh
doesn't seem to realize where i am i
just killed them
i just killed jacob look out there's two
hands on you he has friends
oops i keep thinking i have gas [ __ ] you
have good aim
i think we got and i do not like it yeah
they're dead yeah we got it they're good
good stuff
no mine is still here mine is still here
so around here come come to us come to
us
okay oh i see them on the ceiling there
i don't know if i'll even make it though
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
eat a potion you know what i'm saying
i'll teleport right behind him okay
let's go invisible
you see them oh i think i have a sniper
ability
oh cool where does anyone have eyes on
target they're here
they're here they're right i see there
we go i see him
well you do have a sniper ability dude
that's cool where'd they go
are you about to get [ __ ] up oh we got
them they gone dead is where they're
going
all right exactly we left them unexiled
didn't we oh did we
okay unexiled you want to exile that one
jacob
exiled that's what's up give me your
belt
that's what's up my pants have been
falling down now
you are exiled i hereby
exile thee to the tension
visibility roon yeah that's what i've
been using they didn't see me when i
snuck up on them but then i just got
overwhelmed quickly so
i really shouldn't be using that
teleportation all willy-nilly like that
i miss wolf jacob do you miss wolf
because i do
i miss wolf are we inside i like
teleport though teleport's nice
oh
[Music]
i need to heal
uh is this game boring no this is this
is really fun oh i'm into it so far this
is like only our third match but
i'm into it yeah which one i guess we're
in the circle because i think we
probably still have a lot to learn
there's a
very an armor shard here
i'm pinging okay yep but up up up he
says i see
i see hello okay so we should just
confirm that yup it up up up means
enemies
yeah if someone makes like sudden noises
uh it probably mean enemy
i feel like we just [ __ ] them but
maybe we didn't are they dead
now they're [ __ ] dead get wrecked bro
let's stand around them in a huddle oh
someone's shooting someone's shooting
yep they're still over here they're over
here exile the [ __ ]
i got a heel uh that's cool jaycon thank
you
um i am not like
uh i'm sure we'll talk about the
the series x on inside gaming tomorrow
but uh
being that it was rumored forever and i
already sort of knew about it
i'm not super interested in this leak
didn't uh grab my
thing is not hit scan okay they're
running
where are they you gotta ping on them
out they just shut the [ __ ] out of me
with this
nice sniper crap okay that's where they
are i gotta get closer to them do
anything
they have an ice sniper i do not
oh there's another one right here yeah
i'm coming i'm coming
[ __ ] where are they
[ __ ] can i rosy when you've not been
exiled i can okay
yeah exile prevents rez
there you go boss stay you got your
[ __ ] thank you very much
something about you specifically saying
that is very funny jacob
got you [ __ ]
who did that did you do that oh gosh
mage
i'm teleporting behind them no i'm not
okay now i am
they have no ammo
i'm trying to snipe him
first uh i see him
ah here guys
i don't wanna i don't okay no that works
let's do it there
[ __ ] ass did i get him uh no he's not
dead but we're kicking his ass so much
that he we should kill him
yeah he's on the road he's fleeing nice
where is he pretty good i don't know i
think
yeah over there okay
oh my god that that uh teleport is so
cool
i like it oh my god
is that what i'm reading oh that's
higher than me that's for sure
i gotta consume my armor shards he froze
the ice
what
i gotta drink my health potion i'm on
i'm in a bad spot
well help me finish him off help me
finish him off he's so low
i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying maybe
he's there i don't know not not sure
there we go you got him
oh there's another one oh there's two
still running there's a whole bunch
getting after him getting after them
johnny you're right heal up
to your right to your right john oh you
see i got him i got him
wait where did that [ __ ] just go
where did that [ __ ] just go
right here
don't get pincered
yeah this is uh this is we got some kind
of battle royale in our hands here huh
yeah for real a real uh royal battle i'm
thinking
what air one here he's trying to ice me
okay we're inside the ring yes yes
excellent it's wonderful love that for
us
oh i slid into the fire accidentally
oh no we got mr freeze over here
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] with my orb oh
yeah look at that i thought i was like
glitch before but
i got done i got done i was trying to
heal and then i slid down a mountain
into fire and then i
got flanked and it did not go well for
me
we're coming up nope yeah
nice that was fun very intense
i like this i i tell people better i
really don't care about winning i just
like
fighting yeah totally totally in
agreement
goddamn wizard i'm excited about
learning these abilities
i guess i got the first exile
oh that's neat congrats bro that
teleport's real cool
it goes really far yeah it looks cool
good at sneaking up on people i see that
oh
yeah i gotta rate my experience i
skipped
a very satisfied wow that's [ __ ] rude
john
i did have a performance issue there i
like how the gameplay feels
indifferent to the map all right yeah
oh i can only choose one uh
let's go with that i got a new uh
talent i guess okay where are you
finding that i feel like i'm not paying
enough attention to the level system
right are you on the
select your class screen go to that i'm
on the play
screen unready click ready there you go
yeah and ready and then ready okay on
the bottom right there's a
that's right yeah okay nope i [ __ ] it
up
and then ready okay so it looks like you
have a pool of talent points
i see that's the only restriction
talents come in three categories select
the talent you want to enable here oh
okay i don't have a high enough rank to
get all six to fill all six slots
interesting
i'm ready i'm gonna ready up as well i
guess i'm already ready
that's what i already have got it okay
you're a wizard ready
to ready uh i can't afford any i can
afford one of these but i don't want it
so
confirm all right let's go firm
hell yeah i need to
find a freaking wizard belt keep my
pants up ooh what's that that's cool
uh how is my head eye going uh thank you
for asking gmc we're currently in the
middle
stage where uh the top of my head is a
white yellow
it's just it's just no silver in it um
so
there's a separate step that i have to
take thank you for your consideration
dying hair is really difficult by
yourself it's not a good time i miss my
hairdresser
i wouldn't recommend it to anyone have
you ever died you had jacob
have i ever dyed my hair yeah no not yet
shall we go to north fall village my
leash
oh where is that it's the little star
no okay we can't shadow grace forest
perhaps that'll do oh it sounds
beautiful
let us journey onwards i hope we find a
cottage there
there's a big old castle where people be
dropping nearby let's go to the castle
then
the castle i'm going to the castle cool
all right oh my chest spinning why is my
chest spinning
ghost chair must be spooky ghosts yeah
smell on your chair
wow
oh i thought that was one of you yeah
yeah yeah yeah they did they did they
did they super dead
okay and i thought that i it was one of
you i was like why did you land next to
me
i'm on him alana helped me oh sorry uh
i'm i'm helping jacob
jacob you want to exile that [ __ ] and
then i'll go help john yeah
i think i'm all clear here exile
complete be gone
fool [ __ ] got him that was a
satisfying thing hi
oh [ __ ] i moved slightly no uh i saw a
fart gas appear
okay you sure it's not just gone
no it's like here over here over here
oh i got the teleportation ring
that's cool all right i'm distracting
them
we got him we got him oh you did okay so
how does this rune walk
oh no that's not what i wanted i need to
put my i need a belt damn it
yeah really could use belt
let's say we got a ways to go too
okay i gotta get rid of my because i
know how to use it
um i need more things
i want a cool ability dang it large
armor i just want to be able to howl at
a [ __ ] man that's what i'm saying
i'll open this chest and see what's
inside
i got a huge oh my god it's a scroll of
a mind
what's this do oh no
what was that oh yeah did you do that
thing that was me that was me okay
the ice thing is definitely a snipey
yeah dude the icing is
dope okay it looks like a cool ice
crossbow
it is pretty neat does anyone want some
where armor is concerned i may have just
been not looking though that is a
classical lot of problem is not seeing
anything so directly in front of me here
are some boots
here is an ambulance here is sean uh if
anyone finds a
belt thank you bless you i pinged it you
beautiful man
i'll climb up on top of this hill and
look for enemies look for dark wizards
did we exile all of our enemies
yeah yeah yeah so did we open all those
epic
chests i don't know that we opened
everything not sure about that bunch of
them
[Music]
i'll stand over here and see what i see
oh yeah yeah that was
f i see all right yeah we'd better head
towards circles but
okay scroll of the body anybody want an
epic stone gauntlet because there's one
right here
i'm liking the elements i got man uh how
do you use the um
so i have the frost gauntlet which is
the
is this the sniper oh it is it's lt
never mind i figured it out
yeah it's fine it seems like first
circle is super slow
jacob did you ping that thing i didn't
oh yeah it must have gone away there we
go
i'm on my way oh i can confirm it there
you go
oh it's interesting i didn't see
so you can deny as well be like hey that
ping ain't right
the peng sucks bro
all right okay so let's go okay
let's go um a lot of open ground
between uh yeah i see a little cottage
down here
i'll go to the other side see what
awaits uh y'all aren't running
in the direction of the circle though
yeah but that's because we found cool
stuff
john makes sense
i'll open this chest and we'll be on our
way
cool i'm going to read my scrolls
yeah i could take that i could use this
oh circles here we
[Music]
i'll teleport over there and leave you
in the dust
oh wow it really is all used wolf rune
oh you got wolverine
oh good that'll that'll be good for us
oh my god it's coming
yeah it's on me it took me
it probably doesn't do much damage
skills oh yeah
no it's doing very little very little
uh for those asking i'm still in l.a
make your vision all weird
oh god uh i know that i'm still in it
and
i'm still in l.a too me too
we all i guess not in l.a but near la
far away is the thing yeah what the [ __ ]
we uh we should have listened to john
there's a there's somebody over here
there's several people over here
do you think if i use my invisibility
room i will go invisible to the storm
oh there it is yep
how the how far do we gotta go
get some of these health potentials
we're almost there we're almost there oh
yeah yeah you're right
there's a fight going on right on the
other side of it so okay let's just get
it safe
and then be ready to battle yeah oh i
just killed something
all right did you just finish them off
at the end like jumped out of the circle
and then i punched him in the face
there's someone
right here right on me okay right i'm
gonna heal real quick
where are they oh you killed them jeez
you killed them real fast
i think they're in the middle of a fight
so i'm just like mopping up
i keep hearing sounds it could just be
us
making sounds
i already got that um what am i doing
all right
i need help i don't have any health
posts yeah i didn't either i have so
many armor ones though
oh there's a circle yes yes
it is i think it's closing yet it looks
like it was moving right there i see
somebody
where i pinged purple pink okay purple
paint
i see someone up there oh yeah what do
you want to do then on my blue
go for left boy let's go for left boy he
seems alone
he does seem alone oh no there's a
second one behind him
confirmed left boy not alone
there's a bunch of them right there yeah
oh they're gonna be going for that epic
loot or whatever the [ __ ] it is well
let's do it let's [ __ ] get it
okay yeah okay oh a lot of people
where are they do you think they ran
um surely not there's surely not every
single one of those [ __ ]
fire here oh you don't say up there whoa
that looks cool
someone right there over there
over there oh right here they're
flanking they're thrilled they're
skilled
they're doing flanks
i keep pressing r to reload one of
them's almost dead
yeah one of them's low i'm consuming at
almo
there we go got it
well i mean i have eyes on two right now
how many are there in total this guy's
very little
there's one this one is almost dead i
tell him this guy right here is also
the one running right here there oh
there's two up on the hill over here
behind us
okay [ __ ] all right got that one got
that one
where my ping is there's a mountain yeah
this guy's doing a bit of damage on me
i'm about to drop you'll have to go
without me
[ __ ] okay we got him
we got him we got him we got it i got
one probably not gonna get this one this
is i'm taking unnecessary risks here i
don't feel good about it i guess
you're so far from us yeah a lot of come
back i'm taking a massive unnecessary
risk by exiling someone right now
oh god it was unnecessary and i did it
oh okay
cool this guy is coming for you he's
right there
up there up there oh i already have it i
tried the middle mouse and i ended up
oh someone throw rocks out
you got got all right well i hadn't
healed i yeah i'm not doing well oh i
need to [ __ ] uh
yeah i'm coming i'm coming me i don't
have any health potions
um let me get you john
yeah i'll try to cover you i only have
all my but i gotta do that
yeah they are all right
oh i'm out of your heels yeah me too way
out of heels
so i'm closing in should we oh geez
look for uh look for tools or should we
just i mean the thing's closing in right
now i see one
at the top of that trying to i don't
like ping them i mean john and i both
really need
[ __ ] help through the air you want to
go get him yeah
i hear someone to the south by the way
justina
they're here there's a bunch of them at
this little [ __ ] farm here
oh my gosh this is i can't even see
what's going on yeah i know that there
are a lot of people here but
i don't know what to do about it guys
i'm scared hold me
there's one over there
[Music]
oh behind me
i need to bail i need a bail i need a
bail he's almost dead i wanna
oh i'm getting i'm getting uh i'm
getting some lag yeah good
oh jeez that was not what i meant to do
jesus oh boy
oh the lag is quite bad i got one
i'm exiling him oh [ __ ] i got done
because i was healing someone got me
from behind there john they're sort of
up the hill
yeah oh there's two of them there's two
of them uh
i'm fading away actually yeah i'm not
sure what it happened to me but
the game was freaking out the lag was
not ideal there
all right look out there oh that guy
there's there's two fighting there's two
fighting
they got me running i'm coming towards
you guys there's one right next oh there
he is
beat him up oh he's doing one of them
wow wow
yeah [ __ ] them up whoa
was that it was that the the stone that
just like flung
there's a bunch of people zooming i am
just not ready for this john i
i i have no health i caught i have no
help
oh oh you need a rose okay i'm helping
jacob that guy got me
were you down now i got one okay you all
down there that's another one
it's just one right there the problem
right now is that i
very squish okay there's one up there
yep got it
okay uh jacob can i try and get you on
get me alana you can get me
[ __ ] why isn't it there we go
there i have no heel high in the air
okay we got you
i really need to just consume some alma
you know how it be
my dudes i'm drinking a big ass potion
right now
i know i [ __ ] know i can't stole my
john you're back
up i'm back up cool okay i got wolf
which i feel good about so let me just
wolf real quick
yeah there is a [ __ ] right here
okay i'm coming over the building right
now amma
i have no heels oh armor heals
god die [ __ ] yeah nice work
nice oh we won we won wow we did it
that was very intense at the end good
job everybody yeah that was stuck up
pricey
i mean spicy i said pricey they're real
spicy
good stuff it costs a lot of a lot of
always a galleons
in damage damn look at us go
she oh my god i've never won so much in
a battle royale
i know what is happening this has to be
a trick
something's not right
actually hit things with these damn
fireballs here jacob you gotta come
into my chat and thanks specimen for uh
gifting you a sub
especially oh i'll be right there yeah
specimen
who i uh lovingly referred to as
specimen
hi specimen i'm on my way max rune shot
plus one rule queen now i don't want
that no i'm good with what i have bro
i'm getting you
just
i didn't see their username yet oh geez
oh boy
lobbies in battle royales really need
like a
like a deafen button yeah
yeah it's just a lot everyone was just
standing around
shooting yeah guns i do not care what's
happening in this small room
no
okay well so i feel like it's your turn
fall village is open now
let's do it
i'm so excited this game is free to play
ladies and gentlemen yes
it is
[Music]
the spice of victory has seasoned our
blood check
okay uh shall we drop in the thing that
looks like amazing epic thing let's go
right to the air okay
okay okay really getting ballsy out here
hang on let me agree with you damn it
there is somebody dropping near us so
heads up i pinged one
it looks like there's like three of them
well we'll go to the one you pinged
because that is the sensible thing to do
cool okay
whoa what the [ __ ] it's like in a hole
okay your eyes out keep your eyes out
okay we can go get all of the epic ones
if we want
maybe not a rear wind gauntlet here
somebody needs that
gimme gimme what is in
what do you have
you can have that read read bro do your
reading bro i took it
yeah you guys you good um okay
are we there's another epic over here
okay we're also in the middle of the
circle sweet arm
dab in the middle everything's coming up
us oh max
that was an accident
came to the uh oh there's a fight over
there in that game i'm on my way freight
is getting
i don't feel ready for a fight you guys
i've got no idea
we all ready for it there's a house
right here
there's a house right here i wanna think
they don't have armor either how do you
know that that's true
we gotta strike fast strikes they could
have had hot drops bro
this is battle royale uh it is yes it's
all about aggression
no not necessarily stop playing
defensively and playing offensively and
pub g
i got so many wins you do have to play
offensively but it's not
you know that's not the whole tank wait
weren't there people over here nuance
yeah they all went to the north okay
they polluted this area
the battle went the battle went i just
don't like the toxic i just don't i
don't want it i want my frostbite
that's never good when the battle goes
north instead of south
okay oh oh john
i've killed them already they're dead
and one of them's dead wow beautiful
walk jacob
krusty boys wizard jacob it good wizard
read this real quick top of my class uh
i need a [ __ ] belt gryffindor
shut up actually according to
um cross referencing of several online
quizzes i'm a ravenclaw allegedly
i'm a ravenclaw i i i have decided i'd
probably be
probably be hufflepuff i think you're a
bit of a gryffindor john
i could see you being gryffindor um it
could also be harmful
is it isn't that the one everyone wants
to be because that's what would
protagonist is damn rita
yeah that's why it's lame yeah all the
protagonists are dummies except for
hermione
liking gryffindor is the guy right there
yes superman oh yeah yeah i see him i
see him
and another one a bit further down i'ma
come kill this [ __ ] invisible
coming in hot all right [ __ ] you are
coming in hot that john coming down oh
wait there we go
i don't know destroyed that [ __ ] oh you
hit him with an ice thing
oh my god sometimes you just got to hit
him with another
gifted subs nice thanks
jacob use it once easy one two two ones
you can upgrade that specifically you
distracted me with your generosity
got him i can't see [ __ ] yeah they're
just
just a lot of fire in the flames but
through the fire the flames we carry on
bro
i got the kill i still want to have a
belt you guys so hit me up if you see
someone else here there's somebody here
okay they're very low on health
oh yeah chasing them out of town i shot
him in the face with ice awesome
you think you can get away from here you
son of a [ __ ] she crushed him with rock
[Laughter]
i need to find a damn belt yeah me too
we're still in the middle of the circuit
all right
we don't need to go
i would love epic belt that would be
easy
yeah yeah i see you thank you boss okay
oh this is a pretty good drop said you
found a wolf yeah i got wolf
nice i have kelly yeah start a wolf and
start finding us some uh enemies i'm
wolf and i'm wolfen
that's how we found that last one uh do
i want to drop that how do i
probably not know
okay i'm cool with it let's go
uh colin said it was 121 degrees in la
the other day you feeling okay yeah i
got my icon fixed
so i'm good but it has been just real
hot
my car or my uh
breakers cannot handle it really oh john
i gotta catch up real quick i mean
so trying to plug in i got a warning
that if
l.a didn't like handle it [ __ ] properly
that we would have rolling power outages
um because i guess la like
while most people have air conditioning
the city isn't
structured for everyone to be using it
all at the same time because everyone's
at home
um so that is possible
they're dead
i knew they were just good quickly um
but for that like period of two weeks
where it was really hot and my air
conditioning didn't work i was sweating
so much that i now permanently have
a rash on the back of my leg from just
sitting here oh no
doing fun house work and sweating yeah
it's nuts
you're [ __ ] hot maybe that's why my
ass itches all the time
could be man it could be i will take
those boots y'all i am [ __ ] kitted up
right now yeah me too i know i am too
okay
make sure to bring your shields back up
and whatnot use those armor shirts
i ran out of shots actually oh [ __ ] if
anyone has
there's some over alana there's a one
over here
okay thank you i appreciate that
appreciate it okay we are very exposed
so keep your eyes open
yeah but we're also like op as [ __ ] so
it's over there
okay there's a fight going on that
purple let's go
[ __ ] them up it is almost outside the
ring though
of their shoes yeah i think i got shot
at
oh yeah so i'm gonna take that and then
i'm gonna i'm gonna use it real quick
i'm gonna use it i'm gonna use it
and then i'm gonna get into the fight
probably a bit late on that one it's
fine
oh i think your fire might have just
hurt me there jacob so
what is that a thing that happened i
don't know i think it might have two of
them
yeah i see him i see him john where'd
they go yeah what did they go how the
[ __ ] did that happen
back there jacob there's one right
behind you
oh yeah actually in front of you you're
fighting
[Laughter]
okay i need to bring my god up i need to
bring my shards back up i don't know
where either of them went though oh yeah
i could call i need to do that too
oh somebody sneaking oh behind this
there's one behind us at the yellow okay
yeah
you had there yep two of them
closing in we gotta move are we not in
oh [ __ ] why not
okay let's let's go to the ring i think
and and just as long as you get close to
like where the white and the blue meet
it's very very slow there so you don't
have to like rush
uh they're still sniping us well me rava
uh protect you
okay now okay oh there's two of them
here there's two
i'm shooting at him i'm shooting at him
[ __ ] do this
oh my oh my where'd my tornado
yanked my boulder to the side yeah the
yank in my fireball yeah so
i get the impression that you can
combine spells like we could maybe
usefully combine our spells as a team
over there they went into the labyrinth
oh that's kind of cool
oh my flying ran out right at the wrong
time i
don't know where the heck they went
though yeah they are going away from the
circle
should we just move into the circle
mayhaps
oh we can get closer yeah no rush right
now i mean they're just going to come to
us anyway right
yeah they have to push in this way oh we
got a loot thing over here
i love being able to just jump up and
legendary uh
toxic gauntlet there yeah yes i know
toronto i love this [ __ ] bee move
big fan big fan um
anybody got any eyes on any nerdy wells
i see some over there there's some over
there
wolfed it but there is nobody near me
they're moving this way it looks like
okay there's two over there they're
flying
i'm just gonna fly
we are on the corner of the ring the
border
rather uh circle okay [ __ ] yeah right
there i know i know i fixed it all right
there it is oh there they are the sky
upon us
wow that's a lot of elements happening
at once
ah crushed them nice job got him okay
there might be more got him jacob
how to cancel spell oh two of them
couldn't do it
okay
oh how dare you eat that far
oh it's close get your [ __ ] ass back
here god damn it okay there's another
one right there
both of them both of them are oh another
one right here right here
he's just right here he's not going dead
he's dead he's dead
no there's there's still one more though
we got to move to the circle yeah
yeah yeah oh it's not losing anymore
it's not closing anymore
here [ __ ] i'm invisible john i'm getting
you sniped
i'm being sniped and i can't move up and
we'll get help okay we got it we got it
we got it
thank you
all right i'm healing oh teleporter over
here yeah are two i'm healing yeah look
out there's ice snipers okay
yeah they are they're really real
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i got i sniped i know it's nuts
i wanna meet you under this rock okay
oh [ __ ] i didn't realize you were down
down i got eyes on him from a different
angle but we got you bud
damn and i just used my large heel
that's abominable for that's what you
get from your mind right now
alana you got to do this you got to do
this when you're healing okay
i learned your hard way it's got to
dance a bit don't close again
okay am not doing great
oh there are above us from the to the
right over there there's a couple of
they're having a wizard what is right oh
my god no we're suckled by them you guys
they are they are nothing right around
us here these two seem to be fighting
though so
they are ice sniping they are eyes
sniping away definitely want to get
right in the middle of that
yeah i feel good about how we just
did that that was nice
that's a nice sniper yep yep i am out in
the open i am exposed
no you're invisible mate okay uh they're
behind you jumping
through the air
well you can't shoot through walls so i
okay i see him one of them just teleport
stop running coward haha
okay okay okay there's still one right
here right here right here right there
oh you're dead you're [ __ ] dead
gotcha that's the wrong one
holy [ __ ] uh i have no shield
and very little health if anyone has any
of those heels i've got a little bit
not over yet a building or something
can't use any of this um
yeah heel up oh we gotta go to the
circle let's close it
this might this might not bode well for
us you guys
this is the end right here it could be
[ __ ]
it's this is just us and then there's
only five people left
got one we did get one yeah
where is the other one they gotta be
running here or something
here oh [ __ ] i gotta heal they got me
out of here they got me they
yep i'm coming john i'm fading away you
guys just [ __ ] kill him just kill him
he's one shot check everybody oh no oh
i'm trying to get him
okay i'm invisible whoa what are you
sure there's just one i feel like i just
saw
uh
that was intense that was intense guys
we want another one
fastest fastest clap in the world
you can't even see it it's a blur you
can't hear it either
oh my god that was a rush
but you keep winning jacob is the
greatest twizzler no more wizard school
for you
oh are we gonna get in trouble for using
our spells outside of hogwarts
oh gotta be seventeen you can't fly your
car to school
remember when in the fourth book
suddenly
the ability to teleport was in the book
it would have been real handy in most of
the situations yeah if they could have
used that like
infinitely more frequently i just can't
get any of this [ __ ] because it's left
behind rank
okay so it says i'm class rank four
but this thing is rank three and it's
locked why is that happened
yeah yeah makes sense i don't know i'll
figure it out whatever
yeah whatever we don't even need to know
yeah true
i'll figure it out at some different
different points out i'm only capable in
a battle royale if there's no guns and
there's
wizard powers i thought that i would
really like
destiny battle royale yeah you would oh
maybe
don't don't let uh don't let bungie hear
you say those words and i get ideas
i'm surprised they haven't already
honestly
what's that what's that hyperscape is it
called ubisoft
that's a ubisoft yeah yeah i feel like
jacob you'd be good at that
because i don't even know a thing about
it
all i know is that it's futuristic ah so
the closer it is to the destiny genre
yeah
the better i'll do
dance danny
so high all right where are we going
lowland outpost fever break wait where's
that
fever break oh wait uh what have you
done oh gosh
oh boy all the way to the right all the
way to the right
okay hang on hang on a few breaks got it
yeah i'm sorry
my my yeah that would have been bad i i
alt tabbed and i was having trouble
tapping back in
okay all right let's see how far we have
to go
i'm trying to go like here right on this
one around on this situation yeah that's
where i'm heading
i've confirmed your ping thank you
thing confirmed
[Laughter]
oh wait there's an epic oh there's a lot
of people dropping here
oh god all right i think we're getting
stream snipes we're getting stream
snipes
i don't think that's actually possible
but that's actually happening
all right i'm gonna go open some chests
got some light
potions i would take that one to the one
i currently have all that lots of dudes
you say
more dudes in the gryffindor common room
i'm not seeing any dudes apparently
trying to get your job people who don't
know how to they're right here
they are right okay
but what if i open this chest first you
know what i'm saying
alana yeah i'm hoping i'm here
yeah get the son of [ __ ] nice we got
him we got him we got him they're still
friends though oh you're right they're
out there
oh maybe just obliterate them sorcery
not available yet
okay i felt like someone was attacking
me from behind but i didn't know where
it's from
exactly there we go they're dead
okay every single one of them and the
women and the children
and not just the men
but the women and the children too god
bless thoughtless
god bless well i'm not done i'm not done
yet there are animals
going on over there
i hate them all right i'm done
that would be done oh you're quoting
star wars yeah oh
[ __ ] i also had to exile some fools
because they never care about this but
i'll [ __ ] take it
boys i got that wolf back i
need a belt as always yeah i too need a
belt
and could use an amulet i ain't got [ __ ]
ultimately there's nothing
okay
there is a belt i will take that that's
awesome
if anyone finds uh frost uh frosty
amulet
uh some dudes not moving over there
and over there according to wolf they
are not nearby
there's a guy shooting a wall it's a bot
great
cool killer i'll help you in case it's a
trap
he's literally just shooting a wall
exile that bot oh there's another we got
another wall shooter over here
a wall shooter yeah they're literally
just
shooting walls they still got stuff we
could take from them though that's
helpful for us so i don't mind oh we got
to keep moving too
we do got to keep moving i ain't happy
with my loadout right now they're live
oh we are very far away yeah we need to
prioritize
oh oh i felt like oh god it also it's so
basic
it's okay it doesn't do much damage at
the initial get guttery
[Laughter]
goodbye anybody anybody see a
fire gun but let me know i'll need that
i think i may have passed one at some
point but i will let you know if i find
another
better belt thank you game
you're welcome made it myself
okay what's this circles closing it fast
oh yeah it is epic chest
oh with an epic belt for some epic pants
yeah dudes over there
how do you know that dude it's john you
saying whatever game is
gender neutral isn't it uh it
technically stands for duds with
attitude so yeah i guess you're just
calling them a dud
does it yeah it's a while and then at
the the wood
where are they right we're out in the
middle of this damn desert they went
into this
one over there over there temple oh that
temple's pretty
that is cool i want to go in there
you do that jake are you flying too yeah
all the flying is cool
white is awesome yeah i see something
purple down there i don't know
let me use wolf there's a there's a epic
like spawner over here not good we're
good
i'm not i need the
sound i never said that joel
oh things closing in it sure is badly
any damage though
oh i'm not a butt he's running past to
be able to kill him [ __ ] kill that bot
get rekt we ran him down a lot ah yeah
you're
uh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
i'm taking hits and i don't know where
from we've got a at the purple marker we
got baddies
okay i um okay i don't feel good about
me
okay leo come to me you want to retreat
okay
we'll regroup here you're dead and out
of this
wow i'm consuming and that's gonna be
the same as what i already have
i need does anyone have any little
shield boys
maybe uh looks like they're fighting
over there
okay for now i only have health heals oh
there's a little shield void here
i'm gonna do you want it i i don't have
any so i could definitely use it um but
if you need it you go for it also friend
hey thanks bro i have 20. i appreciate
that bro you have 20.
yeah then you have a better fire real
bad you don't mean shots
i have way too many health deals okay
yeah i could use some
i dropped four though you need any jacob
um
i'm oh we got another company we got
comments there's the flight room here
you can fly with us
i mean but i have wolf and i feel like
wolf is very helpful for us you know
now oh yeah there's a company here yeah
company
jacob fire it one right there i just
threw a gas bomb floating fire
sucks but i'll do my best oh it takes a
while to get there that's for sure
ah circle's closing
oh it is i got stuck i got stuck i got
stuck that sucked
i got stuck on the environment uh this
is not that did not work well for me
guys uh i'm i'm a exile and i'm not in
the circle
guys i'm fading away fading away yeah i
got yeah i was trying to move but i got
clipped
on right above us john yeah i know i'm
shooting him
all right we got one that did not go
well we got one where's the other one
there he is we might not be able to get
you
yeah i'm trying i'm trying he's so close
john
you've almost got him oh it's fireballs
we got him
oh fire gauntlet thank goodness we gotta
get out of here yeah we're taking two
damage now
oh alana we're coming i'm coming for you
oh wow okay
my health's real low so i'm just gonna
try to get out thank you john you're my
hero
you gotta heal immediately though
because you're probably going to get
caught by the
yep on it that's a good a good team kill
in there guys
yeah that was awesome okay and i've got
it it's not a great death for me though
it was not it was not good for me it was
not
i didn't feel good about it all right do
you want to stick with us
yeah yeah uh oh you guys are behind me
let's wait right here we're very well
you gotta stick with us it's a shot it's
just a butt oh it's a pot oh i think it
was definitely a bot
they scared me i have no shields i don't
either
i mean these bots are collecting some
good stuff geez
oh never mind i picked up a uh
are you guys good down there ish yeah uh
if you pick up a new belt it gives you
full shields oh oh cool
i can't because it says i have equipped
so i guess it can't it's only if you
upgrade
it's playing hold on come back okay yeah
oh never mind you can't circle's getting
small
drop your belt but i guess you can't
yeah i don't think you can drop
something
that you wet my head you put your head
in the game or in real life
you didn't answer um that's an upgrade
don't worry about it okay yeah that's
something this is something i learned
from pub g
if you just get close to where the white
where the circle and the old circle meet
you can just hang out there while it's
closing and you you don't need to worry
about it yeah
checks out close it in i think we're
getting to the end here it's going to
that freaking labyrinth too
if there's only seven people alive
yeah how many bots you know that's
that's the tank that's a good question
i'm gonna go up in this tower or on this
tower
um
okay this edge seems pretty good place
to hang out
yeah you fan of edging yeah maybe
nice sorry i was pinging i was trying to
i don't have the willpower
classic wizard training method uh i
ain't got no shields you guys
oh we should find some uh
there's some down there i think i got
some right here
that's the shields right there you both
you both got shields
okay you do excellent yeah mine's sort
of outside the
circle now so i only have one small
and one small shield thing
all right over there over there on the
mountain where on the mountain oh okay
they're driving
cscsc i shot at them they probably know
we're here
that's okay they don't know why it
appears to only be one okay there's a
third
yeah there's one here and there's one
try and ambush them
okay okay is it an ambush if it's just
you jacob
i don't know if that's what an ambush is
where'd they go
i have no idea again sometimes elements
happen in this game
over in the mountains again jacob you
know everything
right yeah yeah there's one right here
that was about
three years above the labyrinth now
you see them you see them cool
i'll try to get it up before you flee
yeah why don't they keep running away
stormcloaks oh i never took my armor
shots i should have done that well i
guess i only have one so it's a race
they're dead cool oh there's a friend
that got stuck trying to climb the
mountain
i'm already hurting them let me use my
house i do not see anyone
oh there they go john's fight oh they're
low they're low
they're very what's that we blew them up
oh no they're moving they're still alive
up nevermind
there you go i'm switching to lightning
oh boy i fell down the mountain did you
get him no
they fell off the mountain too they're
way down there
oh
there's another dude right here nope my
pings don't ever go the distance that i
want them to
yeah like he's like here somewhere
oh there they are okay
they have no armor take them out
it's got to be it's got to be like 50
bots i bet you as we level up it will
actually
box yeah the people at the end are bots
no i don't think i'm gonna find the bots
sometimes
on the way there are you kidding me
again that's a hat trick baby
again i don't feel like it's deserved is
that oh apparently the dev who is in my
chat said you play up you
you play bots until about level five so
yeah they damn it
all bots i don't think they're all bots
i think it's probably just mostly bought
oh my god are you serious spoilers so
yeah sorry i'm not about that paying a
lot of attention to chat for this one
it's just that uh
it's hard because so much video game is
happening same for mine
whatever we've been killed uh i sure
don't want that
so i think you hmm
i think the idea is that you specialize
in one of these things
yeah because they seem to have their own
levels and whatnot
right um
yeah i feel like this is a thing like
killing pots maybe i should just
pay attention to when i'm not on stream
um
uh just like how the the focus mana
forever and escape is
the talent section works i'm just
unclear on
like what rank am i for each one um
you're telling me that i'm two on
fava is that what you're telling me no
no if they have a little
are you blind maybe maybe
they have little the little elemental
symbols next to them
so like
rank three ice rank three lightning
rank six fart
so i'm class rank four
right in what and what uh conduit
which is uh-huh the literal clause but
then when i go to talents
is what i'm looking at and i have four
of six talent points apparently
but i haven't unlocked see like why is
that rank three but it's locked that's
what i'm not clear which one roon
fluence runic fluency
no my fervor is locked at rank three
and i can't upgrade it
um because each of these things are
different elemental ranks
okay how do you break up your body on
the locked ones
like it says rank six and it has a
lightning next to it and then rank three
and it has an earth next to it oh you're
right
they're all different yeah i see what
you have to level the individual
elements
that's interesting okay gotcha thank you
i didn't realize they were different
symbols
it encourages playing different uh
yeah but i don't do that yeah
i think it's uh it's based on
gauntlet level mayhaps um
which is i wonder if you rank those
things up when you're just using the
temporary gauntlets though too
i would think so because you're
specializing in those particular things
so
what i should actually be doing is
paying attention to which one of those
skills i want to level up
and oh get a rahul kohli what um
where i think he's in my youtube chat i
believe
i believe him did he miss the part where
i was quoting anakin
yeah we'll all get in the game again
well supposedly when we get to
i think they said rank six is what he
said then it stops being bots as much
um okay lads where are we [ __ ]
dropping
let's drop right in the center force
hell kion
i like how kion better
let's do it let's do it let's do it okay
you only level up your main gauntlet
it's the gauntlet you start with
according to chat
that's what's up
okay do you want to just go straight
into the fort
i'm going to that epic okay oh yeah i'll
follow you there
i'll land right next door well actually
it takes 20 seconds
yeah so i'm going to load the couch i'm
going to get loose
yeah go in there armed
is there anyone else oh there's it's the
middle so
there aren't many people i don't think
many maybe some reverse psychology kept
them away everybody goes to the middle
but they don't yeah i mean that's why we
hadn't before right oh i already got the
gauntlet i wanted that never happens
oh i'm getting shot whoa whoa
i want to go up try to come down on them
i i feel like maybe this scam
my aim was really bad maybe i should be
playing this is nothing mountain
keyboard it feels great on controller
though they've done a good job
um i'm out right next to you here john
if you want to
i got you with a rez oh hello
oh thank you oh boy
jacob oh jacob
we just had to kill this person real
quick we got smoked pretty hard right
now
i was trying to raise alana and i got
lit on fire and died okay so
i'm coming look out head towards me
there's another person next jacob i'm
fading away
there's another person right next to me
oh it doesn't long left
i think they might have burned
themselves up yeah which you totally can
do so
thanks man is there anybody alive there
is
yeah there's somebody guarding him yeah
nice jacob [ __ ] got smoked again dude
oh god i'm gonna have to look at all
these tornados dead [ __ ] souls just
chilling in here like jacob i'll save
you
yep oh god i'm in there freaking farts
yep gonna fart on me come on jacob carry
us like you know you can
you have before jacob that i got him oh
you got it
nice uh looks like john is more
disrupted than me right now so get you
on first yeah i'm about to fail
i got you i got you i'm hurt their
friend exploded
so oh that's good they're done
oh is that a fire gauntlet i see oh it's
a shitty one
do you want your shitty firearms
the very beginning of the game boots
boots boots you say we're all i will
take boots
um i think we're in the circle oh my god
this belt that's good
i'm gonna explore this castle a little
see what i can find i stink
i've had that realization many a time
there is something wrong with video game
what um with your game yes my buttons
aren't working
try the mousing am i okay it just
started working that was odd was i
missing something
jacob i pinged a fire gauntlet ooh a
purple one too
thank you are you you're better now
alana yes it like
my equip button wouldn't work for some
reason um
yeah but it's okay now i couldn't pocket
things either of course
we have got danger we have danger
outside castle he says
what power am i using oh it's jumpy
jumps
yes jumpy jumps will get you fam
oh yeah we're gonna smoke this person
they're all alone yeah you're about to
get i'm frozen
about to get [ __ ] mate [ __ ] your day
up
ah got him nice oh they have their
friends here they're stressed
well yep no i'm out you're dead i mean
i'm fading away
i thought i was doing fine but we're
hold on i'll get you
yeah thanks man be careful about it
though maybe okay
hey thanks dion you shocked me
okay we're coming john all right
don't let them get their friend
i don't feel like i should be aggressive
right now because i have no health
exiling his strength you froze him next
to him
that's all i'm gonna say
if anyone finds a belt please let me
know will do
they're [ __ ] dead oh i wanna make
bell for you right here
i love you so much nice come and get it
coming to get it would also love wolf oh
i would take wolf if i could or you
if you want it that's also cool you know
no i don't want it i like flying
i would love wolf okay i need to find
more armor shards
oh here's some armor shirt that's cool
everything's coming up jacob yeah
how about that
oh i got [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i'm here
oh i'm getting [ __ ] getting real
[ __ ] where are they
no i'm just not it didn't i overwhelmed
he's trying to exile me
don't let him jacob please carry me
happen this is not a good game so far
are we playing against real people is
that what's happening
i'm gonna get cut
i'm coming over to y'all this is the
first game where i haven't killed anyone
over here i'm just hanging out here i
got you okay okay okay
i'm behind your horse john you're sort
of hot
congrats boom thank you
okay i need to heal real bad
there's a large health potion right here
where's that good idea how old up we're
okay i think we're okay
i hear the sound i would love that
distance
all right all right we should get out of
the freaking
streets we should we should
uh
it's not this like goofy jump
yeah yeah i am glad to have one that's
my favorite because
there it is
it's so late just so many elements bro
there's two of them yeah i'm coming john
cam oh i might be [ __ ]
got one that looked [ __ ] up was the
other one over back near the castle it's
back here oh right here
there he is hit him
get him hey i'm getting them yeah you
got me but i did a lot of damage
healing yeah i'm floating right next to
one of them
i'm still not entirely sure what the
situation is where it comes to um how
aggressively we should play or not
got one it's one on one you got them all
four of us
orbs the last two fighting
jacob jacob came out on top
john where are you i am so close
yeah this [ __ ] loot everywhere uh
okay let me go okay let's go get a
good job okay i'm gonna [ __ ] pick
this [ __ ] up
scroll of the mind welcome take it
survive
pro that's stressful i found a legendary
fire gauntlet too so that'll help a lot
i already have all of this [ __ ] stop it
stop it and everything i'm going to save
my big heel
and i'll use my smaller heels let's do
this let's [ __ ] do this
let's do this [ __ ] i want to read the
scroll of the mind
all right
let's go over here
okay heal up
that was a very aggressive start to this
round y'all
yeah yeah that's what happens when you
drop in the middle we are outside the
circle now
but it looks like we're close to the
edge okay
uh if anyone has any uh armor
things i do not have any in my i do
hang on let me draw how to drop how to
what to draw
tab yes and then in the bottom right
here is your inventory
uh just drag it out or right
situation drag it out or right click i'm
not sure there you go storm's closing we
got a small circle we're heading to
folks
did you get it might be the end we're
getting to yeah here take this spin the
ball
as a trade thanks all right all right
your eyes open this is get we're getting
to the end of it
i will just keep wolfing were those
those couldn't have been bots we were
running into
they actually like people oh yeah
they're really good bots
yeah like the best ai you've ever seen
it's like last of us two ai yeah am i
right am i right
we're okay we're okay
there's fighting going on over there
near that bridge there's also fighting
going on up there should we go to the
old
or do we want to just like take it a bit
chill
i'm gonna go in that fight okay but
where's the fight over there okay
buddy
[Music]
oh fire's coming at you yeah we're
shooting at you from somewhere okay we
have our own fight
to deal with i guess as it turns out
there's a giant hole in the ground i
think you guys they're shooting
down into that show there is a giant
horror ground
as it turns out uh our stealth approach
was not very stealth or very approach
wizards aren't stealthy apparently not
where are they around here
okay i've got a little ways to go i'm
coming though they're a bunch they're
everywhere flying around
[ __ ] that dude up okay
[ __ ] oh i fell in the hole
oh i exiled myself oh my god
what how do you do that i fell into a
hole
oh you can't fall in the hole
it's such a good loadout rmp you guys
don't fall into hulls
jacob i'm here i'm here okay i need help
don't go it doesn't feel good it doesn't
feel good is that the guy you needed
help with
no i ran i'm just saying i was low
okay john i'm right across this little
gulch from you okay
so they're in between us it's to your
right is where i remember
from the dudes there's orbs wandering
around there's some we didn't exile that
are
trying to figure out their situation oh
they're going this way
we should go this is coming towards the
orbs are going this way
void hall is all i'm going to say avoid
hall avoid hole
you see them there's a guy right here up
here
does it count as a hole in one
oh god oh god that's not good
i'm on you jacob i'm on you okay i need
to eat a potion keep pressing r to
reload i don't need it
reload your magic points
oh killed one oh i got sniped ice snipe
there's so many across the gulf there
john look yeah look out look out stay
don't reveal yourself turn left to the
left that dude's super low
super low yeah let's go kill him uh but
keep an eye out for that gulch
oh and i'm out of uh
i'm out of a shield
they're trying to oh i got sniped i was
healing and i got sniped they that
those snipers came over i think they're
streamers
oh you did some good damage though jacob
he almost dead
he's almost dead can you see him why was
why did he just look yellow they're to
the north they're to the north
oh oh jacob i'm scared i'm scared i'm
scared i'm scared
i don't know no you know what i trust
you i was gonna say i don't know if you
should do this maybe we should you
should go pick up john instead of
engaging but you are also the real mvp
forgot about that i don't know if i have
a choice okay it's like
people left also am i reading
that jacob has 10 kills or
what's that yes where about each other
uh god you're a friend oh i don't know
how i would tell you
jacob yes oh it's lacking so much
oh god i can't even see what's happening
oh buddy look how tiny the little ring
is
oh jacob oh jacob oh no
oh my god wait what
what is this i'm doing whatever this is
some sort of ability oh god oh they go
jacob that was really good yeah
oh that was a tough it's so loud why is
it so loud
that's not me oh my gosh that's i think
the person who killed me
you're a great wizard jake i'm very
proud of you oh thank you
how many points for gryffindor or
whatever
okay okay okay okay i don't have rank
six on that obviously i
i might get to rank six on that soonish
which sounds pretty sick
it's mage
getting up getting those points
high romancey i think i'm going to
switch it up let's see
oh uh start ranking something else
that's a good idea i'm gonna go earth
yeah i should see what i need to do to
make something better how do you check
any of that
uh it shows in your talent selection it
knows what the requirements oh i have to
get ready i feel like i'm gonna like
pay attention to that [ __ ] when we're
not on stream i'll like properly read it
and do something
yeah yeah
more like do some stinking you're going
to be yes mage
nice that's so cool
for the fart mage
okay forever let's see what like i
actually want to move on to
next yeah many options
it is oddly quiet in this menu screen
yeah oops i rotated my monitor got
like a wind next
tempest okay
everything okay yeah i punched my
monitor
and then it it's so hard to get three
monitors all
lined up so
i haven't i basically i have my center
one balanced
and then the other two are basically
just kind of leaning into it
um hmm
[Music]
so did this new xbox console leak or get
announced
is it the it's the latest it's just the
s brad sam yeah
it looks very very new yeah which is why
i'm like whatever
already yeah it's about the price i
expected
it looks funny
very funny looking thing so wow it looks
like
it looks like a speaker it's pretty
strange um do you know what the other
one looks like
i mean this one also i promise xbox
wait where are we dropping xbox series
s yeah and it's 299 from what this
particular image says
real cheap oh where are we dropping oh
my god we're dropping right here
okay cool sorry i wasn't paying
attention should we go in the middle
why does it look like that i don't know
we'll see what they what they say about
it i suppose i'm gonna land this i don't
i just don't understand why they didn't
announce it
like everyone knew what just just do it
there's only 40 people in the game oh
you're right
it's supposed to be 60. but did you see
that probably
probably the reason they made it look
like that is so you face it towards the
wall
ah uh i guess
yeah i guess stash room what's the dash
room do i dash a little bit
yeah it just gives you a little dashies
oh that's boots i know it doesn't last
very long
uh that's what i want beautiful
amulet boots the spring step room is
lame as [ __ ]
oh let me know if you guys find any cool
women whatever
oh there's a railway right here and
there's a lighting on it
okay i have some stuff we gotta get john
a belt yeah you do
never mind i found one beautiful i might
just got here
it took me a while i think alana picked
it up okay
uh what and then we'll find another wind
gauntlet nope i don't use wind gauntlet
uncommon wind gauntlet i found that one
there you go
it was probably i pinged where it was i
just got an uncommon one
oh there okay it just wasn't rendering
because that was too far away from me
it's right there
oh found it sorry for accusing you
yeah i was [ __ ] rude dude what the
[ __ ] and for calling you lana just now
that's fine wizards should always be
suspicious of each other i will allow
that
the other thing though never again we're
in the circle too
cool i love that for us there's a little
thing across the bridge i'm gonna take a
look at
okay
let me know if anyone finds a wolf boy i
got wolf what do you have
i currently have spring step which is
the least
of cool of all of them yeah don't trade
with me i wouldn't recommend it
yeah it's super lame yeah you go
bowling good for evading i guess but but
i would prefer to go oh
then boy it does have a pretty short
cooldown too so i guess you can just
bounce around it is really short yeah oh
[ __ ]
not my finest work yeah that's spring
step
rare frost nope nope nope nope nope guys
i'm gonna go that big ass castle way up
there
that is good sure that sounds great do
it
an oh i know
and it's in the circle
[Music]
up bad guy cool
it's a bot yeah i think it is
they're just chilling ah if you had to
move forward
just a second yeah that's totally about
good they bought
oh i've gotten a free empty of warning
good example
well the lawrence raid's about to happen
oh [ __ ] i got here
a what rage a lawrence raid so law
himself
i might take this teleportation room
just out of curiosity teleportation is
awesome
i really like
it's pretty much just like dishonored
teleport
oh cool i love this link that's what it
was yeah yeah exactly
well you're invisible yeah the
invisibility is nice too
but you can't like do any cool moves or
anything devastating oh yeah
okay oh that was just me
i was just testing my teleport sorry
didn't mean to allow anyone
oh my bad oh damn it oh you can't go
there
really it's invisible
zero out of ten worst game of the decade
let's go down there i marked a uh
i marked an epic the yellow thing is
that you oh yeah
that's you now let's go let's go let's
go
thank you to the person who said they
love my hair right now they shouldn't
i'm halfway through dying it
they should 100 get rid of that castle
well i mean it does look cool though
it's just too tempting yeah very much
looks cool but
i feel like everyone who sees it will go
oh got some new ones
they got a new amulet this is the dude
we killed before in it
that's exactly what that was wait where
is john people at where i marked
and the epic thing is gone not terribly
close to us i'm making my way
to smithko okay
i'm looking down the pit right here oh
cool teleport
back neat i'm going i'm taking i'm
getting the high ground
i don't this reminds me of my time in
helm's deep you know
feel me you know what i'm saying
oh i see i see a butt
okay oh i am sniper okay i'm dealing
with bot
okay well i marked where sniper was oh
you flew into the air
i am with jacob
oh this wind gonna let your lame
basically just [ __ ] slide
him in one fell swoop you exiled okay
john i'm coming to you
it's an epic earthquake be banished okay
i'm not used to these abilities
okay i'm here i was trying to shoot wind
oh god but i was just earthing
uh there is a ton of like health potions
and [ __ ] here if anyone
where are they needs any uh from
the bot that i killed like it's a good
amount of ting
oh i see somebody in the sky over here i
see a bot
okay oh god they're writing fire on me
that's my that was my favorite thing
uh where are they where are they here
help me oh right there okay well they're
just straight
oh there's two of them here's my shield
john john come to me
okay i'm coming i'm coming
oh god they're gonna see me they're
gonna see me thank you jacob
okay
i have someone lightning upon them
they're dead they are dead there's
there's there's
another one did they explode no okay
i'm fading away after two pretty good
kills if i say so myself
ow i got you on it i got you bro cause
you're not running towards me
yeah i am uh okay
i need to heal accident
wait hold on before uh let me get that
guy
all right cool let's chill oh we popped
the heels
sometimes it'd be like that
oh getting my tornado [ __ ] got him
[Applause]
um
moana i'm coming for you now i've been
dating you
i'm deeply in danger so are you john
yeah behind you
yeah i'm coming john
yeah this is a formidable opponent oh my
god
uh uh got him i got him john hold
there i go wait what just happened jacob
and so i was like before i get alona i'm
gonna finish him off
yeah it wasn't a good idea i i did have
concerns
i do feel like i expressed them but you
know it's cool it's fine it's chill
the heat of battle what happened i went
up there and he had
basically completely healed so yeah
that'll [ __ ] get you oh i'm so used
to the fire thing now i'm trying to
adapt
that's the that's the real issue i'm
having where i'm like left click
is wind attack but it's not yeah
also a projectile just so that in my
brain goes
left click projectile yeah
all right i need to go wind again
because i need some win barf
yeah i should change it just so that i
can upgrade i'm aware of that
but also i like the lightning so you
know
what what is this you see this thing i
feel like
weird wind things oh god oh that's not
you guys
never mind it's irrelevant no those are
four next to complete strangers
those are slytherins yeah
all right ruby grove
hollywood ruins what
south oh yeah hollywood ruins sounds
good to me
okay oh you want to go wait ruby grove
where are you
sorry i got that's a good night we only
got two seconds
i like the sound of hollywood ruins what
was it actually called i didn't look
teamwood i think
epic oh let's go there's a castle right
next to it i'm gonna land okay yeah i
was gonna
land in the castle too but i'm just
gonna do this open
[ __ ] full area chromatic aberrations
right yeah i like i like the nice music
when you're dropping in that's fun
yeah yeah dramatically part of me
cool good we love that we like this
we'll take this
we will take that we will read this i
just want a damn belt
i know i've never wanted belts more than
in this game as a person who does not
wear belts
this has changed my life i didn't
realize the benefit tina
i haven't worn it down six months stay
inside this thing to get it to activate
yeah i don't know there's a castle next
door
teleportation around here if anyone
wants it oh you're way over there
oh yeah there's a wall i got a wolf
i do need something down there down the
bottom of the hill
okay oh somebody threw my epic
uh yeah this is unconscious
it's also trying to freeze them
they're in my tornado looks like there's
only one
i don't understand my abilities
that's not ideal all right their armor
is gone
what oh i got a sniper
wrong one well fine i guess
boom i got one of them or alana got one
of them i'm first i sure did i showed it
where is the other one oh i'm dead
i died immediately where are they
there's one over by me they're over here
jacob
ah just missed leave me alone son of a
[ __ ]
they're trying to get me okay yeah we go
very nice
oh you can skate on ice
can you oh my god yeah that's pretty
cool
yay thank you
i don't know i guess it doesn't happen
any faster if you both do it at the same
time
uh i need boots and amulets oh jacobs
don't need the belt
yeah i need a belt real bad my pants are
just coming down
it's embarrassing frankly the sniper
the frost sniper yeah i'm a huge fan
yeah we got to move towards the circle
too i need a bigger belt
you do need a bigger bag everyone's here
let's see what's up yeah we don't need
to move
more into the circles some circles
okay just not we didn't do great
in terms of the drop pio tones out
holidays immediately
well there's a bunch of look there's
another epic thing on the web yeah let's
go for it
oh i'm sorry that was me that's me
okay anyone want to scroll the mind i'll
use these boots
uh sure okay great thanks for asking
i'll start howling
i got some wolfies oh yeah i too have
wolfies
oh i feel less special yeah that's like
not even that cool jacob so
everybody's got wolfies these days where
is my
super suit oh no wait sorry hello that
is my wizard robert
your peasant belt currently only have
shitty boots you guys so if anybody gets
any better boots that'd be tight
uh i have a small question small small
health yeah let me drop it for you i
mean i mean you do this here i'll drop
you too
okay i just remembered i can armor
myself now now i have no armor or
anything
yeah probably let me get some elevation
here
oh we got a castle right here we go into
okay
i will please reveal nothing let me try
my wolfies
also revealed nothing oh you think your
wolf is so much better than me yeah it
might be might be
okay probably could be an epic loot
up there ooh armor claw i love that for
me i do need more health factors
i'm gonna take more of that let's just
let's yep
it just rare stone
gauntlet i need a better wind goblin
wrong button i shocked myself to ping
that for you because i was playing it
like apex
and i pressed the bumper i keep
unlocking new skills or something
i just got that too i wasn't sure what
it meant congrats bro oh
oh i heard jacob's footsteps oh i saw a
statue up there
your marker is yeah that's why i marked
it
oh but it's no i don't need them it's
already opened
oh i see people where people down there
if anybody finds school they're heading
our way they're heading our way yeah
there are
two of them probably two it's only two
we can make it work we can make it work
i said all my shit's weak
oh that [ __ ] head shot bro
that was sick there we go nice
you got them i got the other one good
stuff john exile green mean beans or
whatever this person's name is
yeah exactly send them home i said good
day
new boots oh we got some goodies over
here
oh rare boots
[Music]
fire gauntlet i do need to upgrade my
frost feel good about this this is good
stuff i'm glad we killed these people
we [ __ ] dunked on them and i feel
good about it i need
yeah that was awesome y'all
too many spring step runes i want
something cool
my wolfies reveal nothing my alphas do
not see [ __ ]
oh we are inside the circle there's an
epic here i'm going to go okay yeah i'll
come all right
it is right in the middle of this big
old valley keep your eyes peeled i think
i hear magic stuff happening
i continue to not see [ __ ]
what do we got please be a wind gauntlet
in there
i still got a poopy wind gauntlet
i will take boots i will also take an
amulet scroll
nope i already have better boots oh yeah
okay i'm gonna have to depend on my fire
got light i guess
still nothing i'm gonna do
yeah me too i'm gonna go in this castle
as well on this side
oh [ __ ] i need better lightning what
happened
yeah i i tried to land on top of it it
you cannot land on top
too tall [ __ ] oh god i don't see anyone
that way
yeah i'm just low there's like
constantly very subtle chromatic
aberrations around
all the edges i love chromatic
aberration is like my favorite
effect ever
yeah for real oh yeah we're gonna have
to head east
another fall okay we're pretty close
though right yeah it's right there
yeah we're right here i've got yeah i
feel like we've seen less people this
round than we normally do
okay i got a better wind gauntlet
finally oh thank goodness
yeah i could use a better lightning
gauntlet if anyone finds one i have a
basic ass lightning going
right now
[Laughter]
lame i haven't seen anybody in ages i
know it's suspicious
it truly is keep howling i will keep
going and i don't see
nobody i'm flying up yeah i see him i
see some i just smart oh yeah
somebody up there [ __ ] wrong button stop
alana son of a [ __ ] i keep pressing the
bumpers to ping and it's not bumper
it's not bumping a pig they're up on
that mountain fighting each other it
looks like
captain cook is climbing a mountain i
need to film a mountain a rare belt
uh yeah i could use a cool belt oh
it's only rare it's not epic so [ __ ] it
dude's right there dude's right there
dude right there i pinged it where did
he go where did he go
where did dude go though oh yep they're
moving right here hillary i'm right on
him
you stay trying to catch up but i can
only spring step my way over
i can't see him where'd they go he's
over here now
he's i think he's alone oh he's behind
the hill he's up on the mountain
i don't know how to use my
we have wolfies keep howling i don't
know where they are now
he's inside here directly in this room
okay i'm above them i'm pretty sure up
on the ground
are you a boss you got to be a bot are
you a bot yep
they're trying to fly away no it's not a
bot because they're running
yeah let's don't know how to run no bots
just stand there and shoot walls
noted where'd they go
uh circle's closing so damn it that's
that
just here there's another one coming in
i don't know where that other one went
well we're just about to kill
you got him done uh so there's another
person right here you see him you see
him coming up
in the sky right now oh there's nobody
on the mountain you're right there are
tons of them
oh boy oh boy this is getting green
crazy oh boy indeed
nice aim right above us right there oh
two of them
they're both dressed in white okay
oh boy oh that's chaos oh this isn't
looking good for me
i need to go ah i'm trying to heal oh
there's so many of them oh boy there's a
couple on you alana
[ __ ] oh okay
one of them is weak i just want to heal
you know you feel me you feel me
yeah oh my god i shot her right in the
air that was awesome keep trying to
predict where they're going to move with
the snipers and sometimes you get it and
sometimes you [ __ ] off
there's one right here yep i'm coming
down from above uh-oh uh-oh
yeah i got
oh there's more i am fading away i'm
going to hide
um sort of close to you here john
oh they're trying to snipe me oh they're
on me they're on me they are on you
oh you're invisible oh the wall oh they
got me they're so close
they're so close oh [ __ ] it's on you
john i'm gonna try to mosey my way down
this hill
there's two on top of the mountain
fighting each other it looks like
and the storms are coming oh
john you're going for it thank you i'm
fading away isn't it doing it no
oh i thought i was doing it it wasn't oh
they haven't noticed you somehow
i think that i may have trapped myself
no i'm good i'm good
oh boy don't kill me oh they're exiling
me i'm being exiled i'm being exiled
i'm being exiled where are you nope
somebody disrupted them oh my god thank
you john
indubitably i need to get some armor
real quick i am running out of time
though
okay uh here you go i don't think you
can do it john yeah
you're attacking me i got one stupid
john just let me die it's okay it's okay
there's too many
you know i'm too many i'm gone oh [ __ ]
you ought to oh jacob
jacob oh my gosh oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh god oh god oh god oh my god [ __ ]
you're right you're right
[Laughter]
we tried man
oh they're chinese i underperformed that
one oh my god and i was going to say
jacob
we we're fighting people from china
okay am i conduit right now my tempest
rank i almost i haven't played
competitive games like this in a long
time yeah this is super fun
i like it was pub g big was that 2018
that was ages ago it feels like that was
the last time
i was like heavy i would say the 2017
maybe
2016. i feel like it was a while ago at
this point well it was in 2016 because
it was when i worked at
funhouse but it's possible 2017.
yeah something like that i think it
back when you worked at funhouse 2017
for f for pubg
okay dudes
hey i hit 69 000 followers on twitch
tonight thanks everyone
oh damn nice
nice nice nice nice i think this is
gonna be my last game you guys
i'm gonna call my mom this is gonna be
your last one
yeah it's mom
okay okay okay okay who's farting on us
we haven't even started yet
that's how they get you
okay so the
lightning i didn't know how the
lightning worked it's projectiles
yeah yeah the lightning strike the one
that i use the most i i just really like
the
the obby the sorry the heavy light scan
no let me find out yeah oh
the map appeared right yep
[Music]
oh yeah hell yeah what's gonna be going
on
let's go let's go let's go
look at that castle i'm getting in there
yeah dog
yeah i'm gonna go to the castle then i'm
gonna go to that epics okay
oh
so fun it's a jolly someone like right
on my ass
i'm liking it oh congrats bro oh boy
take care of that real quick oh boy i
missed the building
i do not want you fire gauntlet there is
a fight i don't want here if anyone's
tagging oh whoa whoa whoa i'm here oh
[ __ ] this combats occurring no i fell
down the mountain i'm about to die i'm
about to
eat it oh god oh god
just trying to get up this mountain i'm
dead
[Laughter]
they're going to exile me not if i can
help it
it's not looking great for me though i i
can't i can't johnny you helping no i
is too they were too aggressive too
aggressive they're trying to exile me
[Laughter]
didn't count all right
[Laughter]
that didn't even happen yeah that didn't
that didn't exist it didn't even happen
it it it made me wind again even though
i was
ice last time so weird
let me uh let me switch
thank you patrick okay all right nobody
saw that everyone in chat
pretend that didn't happen you didn't
see it it didn't that didn't happen
it didn't made up round um we had like
all of us had lag so
yeah that was definitely lag something
that happened
do not worry about it what happens to
every wizard uh yes pedophile this is a
magic battle royale
it's pretty dope yeah i like it
i definitely feel like there are like
there's probably more to this game that
i'm currently paying attention to that i
think after the stream i will take a
look at
it's probably a little bit deeper than
we're even letting it on
as let me actually see
how long will this take to hit oh that's
pretty fast i think i've been leading
people too much
oh really okay yeah i know the map is
like a it's like a jump scan every time
i'm like
yeah how about wayfarers crossings
my mouse was over my mouse is over
oh my god bro that's [ __ ] crazy dude
that's nuts that's nuts
this game is so fun yeah we're doing a
gameplay for fun house this week uh john
oh cool hell yeah i think it's me and
adam that i scheduled
you guys can teach adam how to be a real
wizard i know i was like well i what if
we did bat royale but we don't give adam
gunn
then what happened then how to how adam
do good
yeah how adam do
oh i missed
i don't know what the fetterfall rune is
you can have that i don't even want it
but sure
that's true do you even take fall damage
in this
uh also i have not played dnd no it's
just
slow fall though oh i'd love to but um
remember when i used feather fall when
those uh when those witches were after
us
and we jumped oh we jumped up that was
the most disastrous quest i think i've
ever been on in tnt
it wasn't even a quest we just came upon
a house we were like hey let's check
this out
let's go in there let's see yeah all
went bad you guys have friends well we
found a child in a cage and we're like
yeah this won't fly yeah yeah
all right well what's up what is it what
is that curse of strod is what we're
getting
oh i miss it dearly okay feather fall is
actually so cool
um i need more things and i'm not a
oh no dan have to go and have his baby
yeah hey guys well you could
i think i nixed it because it was so
random when it would happen that i
i like i don't know
and then it also started being like once
every two months we would play
yeah i don't know it was they're leading
up to dan having a baby it's like okay
so yeah i can't really probably ain't
gonna happen anymore
guys my loadouts apparently [ __ ]
garbage so
um i'll take the fire gauntlet but right
now
i have trash i just want you guys to
activating how old he's
oh you don't have a little buddy anyone
has belt oh alana has
no belt no i don't have anything there's
two two over here did you just
get him did is that a battery you pinged
or a belt you picked a belt
that's a baddie okay they might have a
belt yes what did batty have built i
didn't snipe him
oh i missed oh yeah i love the snipe
it's good
it's good you can load it as well by the
way um like charge it
charge it up yeah
oh that's the only way you can aim i
guess but ah
there it is oh and there's drop off
the flight rune
a flight rune's fun uh they're in the
castle straight ahead
okay flight room my favorite so i'm
gonna be
favorite yeah there's still two here
floatation rune
i'll take that over over there somewhere
yeah they're fighting each other it
looks like
there's one where my orange marker is
ah oh jesus
snuck up on me you're dead and out of
this world
i'll take that oh they're on me all
right lads picking
danger i'm coming to you larry i'm on
you i'm coming to you jacob
okay i'm you i'm skating on my eyes on
you
but i don't see them there they are okay
two of them
don't mind me could you shoot me a
health potion i like them i snagged him
he's behind you jacob all right cool oh
boy thank you for that one i got one
exiling chase it after milan fly forth
trying oh they didn't have belt
they did not have belt [ __ ] i still
don't have a belt so i got you zaba
oh you son of a [ __ ] there we go nailed
him
got him nice nod 6969 is definitely not
a bot
there's a belt right oh my god a belt an
epic belt
i'm going to read this scroll of body
don't mind me just getting my reading
my shield and stuff back okay get my
armor back
get my health back yeah i'm still
feeling
like a mess right now under equipped
don't feel good
i still have no abuse let's see if we
can find some stuff
you want to use your halley's first
jacob oh i just got rid of the hallie
sorry oh let me get the halley's why'd
you drop the hourlies
oh yeah uh over where the purple marker
is inside this tower here
thank you you want to go to oh actually
that's right on the edge of the circle
circle spot to close are we in the
supple yeah we're in the circle
ruby grove yeah i'll head wherever i
just went ahead
thank you not one more towards the
center i've played
a ton of neville winter actually have
you guys played neverwinter never winter
night
no just neverwinter it's the mmo that's
based on dnd and
and it's one of my favorites probably
guild wars 2 still probably my actual
favorite
that sounds cool yeah so people can make
quests
that like like other people can write
quests uh it's [ __ ] dumb
i don't know but i leveled up oh i was
excited yell
people make some qualities yeah people
can mmo people can write quests for you
okay so
people are at the purple marker right
now there's three of them
purple marker three of them okay we're
frosty
here if anybody needs that i don't feel
prepared to engage
right now uh i don't have any health
potions well they're coming for us
okay great cool all right well engaged
we shall land i guess where are they
they're down
they're down at the epic spawner oh
i see him there's three right down there
yeah
i think that's the three teams it looks
like yeah
is that a different three to the ones
who engaged john
tried to how me
why did the words equal opportunity just
keep coming up that's a weird yeah i've
had that a few times too i don't know if
that's a problem you keep doing that
some of your gear or something
i did move in more
that wasn't useful i didn't do a good
job man i made a mistake this is a big
mistake
oh i froze why i'm flying away
okay john i'm coming in one of them's
one of those one shots i got one of them
there's this friend there oh
all right got him got him one one hit
one over here one over here
he's weak he's right yeah he's close to
being down though look at him there we
go there we go got him get rekt scrub
nope exile
exile for you his friends his friends
this way his friends towards me because
that's the way the orb was running
okay i got very confused because i
killed a guy whose name was bro you got
a mic and i was like how are you
speaking to me
i'm confused what are you asking me and
why
heading towards you uh let me take that
where'd you say they went
oh fire fire on me okay let me get
myself some armor
getting shots i'm gonna fly up behind
them right oh they saw me
all right coming where are they right
over here where i
am on top of me
nope they're dead oh nice get out of
here macho late
when are you dead shaken i've done no
he's disrupted you got him there right
point blank fireball
so the face seems to hurt myself as well
circles here
oh and we're inside it again perfect
we're good we're good we're good
okay i use purple boots and i could
definitely use upgrades to both of my
gauntlets but otherwise i'll just be
chilling
all right i'm gonna read that armor and
get that uh health yeah
true health health health okay cool
um there is another health here no not
what i mean
fit
there's someone right here two of them
right here right here right here really
yup oh yeah i see him down down the road
[ __ ] punk [ __ ] i'm wrecking [ __ ]
both of them sort of in this castle
thing
one of them's kind of hurt already
you sniped me ow ow
my armor they're both on me and i'm
slowed for some reason
so i backed up backed up yeah uh let me
heal real quick
oh i got one when he was flying oh you
got the one
that's okay okay okay i just sniped him
when he was flying
up we got that one you hello oh you're
disrupted oh thank you very much
you got it the other one the other one's
over at the castle over the at the blue
thank you john all right he is oh yeah
one just came over here one just showed
up
ah i was trying to use my uh except
yeah maybe can you retreat john maybe oh
i didn't realize
yeah yeah yeah you get a lana she's
gettable
oh they're they're coming real fast
though they're the rounds
and then i'm gonna heal as soon as i get
back oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what
happened all right sorry
you're good you're good you're good
though
third place we are definitely playing
against real people now that's
all right that's for sure that's what
happened it's actually challenging
this game is funny yeah
thank you for joining me and i want to
play it again yeah
i'm down again yeah it's super fun uh
some victories tonight supposedly
against boss but there's no proof
i don't think that's true i think that's
lies it sounds like [ __ ] to me
i know we're skilled wizards exactly
hey beating against sports is still
beating you know you know what i'm
saying yeah
this could be hard i've played perfect
dark have you ever played perfect with
those
those really hard couple bots that
should [ __ ] up progression
when to win uh thank you play with me
you guys super fun
this is super fun yeah and uh yeah
everyone who's been asking game is
epic exclusive on pc but it's also on
cost all of the consoles and it's
free to play and cross play so across
the board
pretty sick yeah baby good stuff yeah it
sounds like we'll be back
yeah to be wizards again yeah i'm down
later dudes
have a good one all right see y'all
later
um thanks everyone for watching it was
fun
yeah uh i'm planning to stream tomorrow
just so everyone knows kingdoms babylon
re-reckoning comes out and i [ __ ]
love that game
so i will i think do like a stream
actually during the day which i never do
so that's the plan so if you're around
i'll see you tomorrow
after i get all my work done that is